when you think about Batman your mind
probably goes to the grim avenger who
stalks gotham city by night dishing out
a darker brand of justice and you're not
wrong that's the image that's made
Batman one of the most popular
superheroes to ever hit the comics page
and propelled him to success in TV and
movies as well since 1939 though there
have been thousands of stories about
Batman and sometimes things get pretty
weird from bizarre adventures to
long-lost relatives there are more than
a handful of things about Batman the DC
Comics would probably be happy for
readers to forget the dark knock off
after his debut in 1938 Superman's
sudden and overwhelming success prompted
a massive crowd of imitators but Batman
was different the darker costumed the
menacing demeanor and even the fact that
he didn't have superpowers helped him to
stand out in the crowd but unique isn't
really the right word for him Bill
Finger and Bob Kane were pretty much
just ripping off the shadow the first
Batman story the case of the chemical
syndicate appeared in Detective Comics
number 27 in 1939 but three years
earlier the shadow a pulp hero known for
his dark costume and menacing demeanor
starred in a novel called partners of
peril to say that Batman's first
adventure borrowed from that story is
the understatement of the century
it's a beat for beat adaptation right on
down to Batman's early pension for guns
and his identity being revealed as a
millionaire socialite the good news is
that within a few months finger and
artists like Jerry Robinson and Sheldon
mauled awfully separated the Caped
Crusader from his inspiration and hey at
least he's not alone just ask Superman
if he knows anything about Clark Doc
Savage and the Arctic Fortress of
Solitude he had in 1938 my brother my
Deadman and me way back in 1974 is
world's finest number 223 Bob Haney and
dick Dillon told a story so weird that
even Batman himself referred to it as
the most stunning shocking thing that
ever happened in my whole life which has
not exactly been dull in a team-up with
Superman and the ghostly dead man
Batman followed the trail of a murderer
who killed his victims with gigantic
razor-sharp boomerangs and discovered
that the man he was hunting was actually
the brother he never knew it seems his
big bro Thomas Wayne jr. had been driven
insane by a car accident from when he
was a baby
he learned how to make boomerangs as
part of his therapy and was then
elated into a very complicated murder
spree and that's not even the weird part
that happens at the end of the story
when dead man a ghostly superhero with
the ability to possess the living just
decides to take over Thomas's body as
his new flesh-and-blood home without
ever telling Batman instead he just
assumes that his buddy Batman would be
cool with it and wanders off to have his
own adventures
needless to say while we would
eventually see more of Thomas jr. no
other Creators ever referenced this
particular story again Alfred goes bad
speaking of weird things that have
happened to the Batman family
Alfred's brief tenure as a telekinetic
crime boss who looked like a humanoid
golf ball is also something that we
don't really talk about anymore in 1964
jack schiff and sheldon mauled off
seemingly killed off Batman's Butler
Alfred having him sacrifice his life to
save the dynamic duo
six months later though Batman faced a
new foe the outsider for almost two
years the outsider challenged Batman and
Robin acting as a mastermind who
manipulated other villains and when they
finally confronted him he was revealed
to be Alfred it turned out that their
faithful Butler had been resurrected by
a scientist whose regeneration machine
turned him into a mutant who hated his
former employers fortunately the process
turned out to be extremely easy to
reverse and before long he was back to
dusting the Batcave and believe it or
not this one actually did get referenced
again later on nocturne ha's custody
battle if you're a casual Batman fan you
might think that he only did weird stuff
back in the long-ago days of the Silver
Age once the 80s rolled around with Dark
Knight Returns and death and the family
things got dark and serious right sure
as long as dark and serious includes a
vampire taking Batman to court to get
custody of Robin it happened in 1983
with Natalya Knight who was about as
close as you could get to a vampire
without actually having someone get
bitten on the neck while working as an
astronomer she was zapped by a weird ray
that drained her skin of pigmentation
and left her super sensitive to light so
naturally she decided to become a super
villain named Nocturna like you do she
also fell into a love quadrangle with
Vicki Vale and Alfred's daughter Julia
who were all vying for Bruce Wayne's
affections the thing is rather than long
walks on the beach Nocturna strategy
involved waiting for Bruce to adopt a
new Ward Jason Todd
and then adopting him first so that
Bruce would have to marry her if he
really wanted to be a bad dad the
weirdest part it almost worked
Jason actually said in court that he'd
prefer to be adopted by Natalya only to
reveal later that it had all been part
of an ill-fated attempt at going
undercover
eventually Nocturna was seemingly killed
in a hot-air balloon crash no really and
that was the end of the world's most
complicated marriage proposal electric
death when you think about Batman's
greatest enemies the names that usually
come to mind are the big ones the Joker
Ra's al Ghul you can even make a pretty
decent argument for the Riddler if you
really put your mind to it but if you're
going by who actually had the most
success at the goal of actually killing
Batman then the Dark Knight's greatest
foe is actually a guy named Lester
Bachynski the electrocutioner yeah it's
hard to believe especially since he
technically killed Batman by accident
the electrocutioner was another
vigilante who figured that if you
couldn't bring the criminals to the
electric chair you might as well bring
the electric chair to them in a 1992
story from Detective Comics he and
Batman were on the trail of the same
criminal when the electrocutioner zapped
him with a shock big enough to stop his
heart
Batman was technically dead for a good
minute and a half the only reason that
he didn't stay that way was that Robin
was there and had the good sense to wear
an insulated costume while the
electrocutioner originally just shrugged
off literally killing the Batman Robin
eventually beat enough sense into him
that he agreed to use his electric
gloves as a defibrillator to shock
Batman back to life and then they both
presumably agreed to never again speak
of the time Batman almost died in a
sewer at the hands of a delish Club that
had to be beaten into compliance by a
spiky haired teenager with a stick the
dark knock off returns with Batman's
popularity it's no surprise that Gotham
City would become a pretty important
place in the DC Universe the last 75
years have seen a history developed for
the Dark Knight's hometown that's also
seen it serve as the home of other
superheroes from throughout the timeline
of the DC Universe the Golden Age Green
Lantern a violent vigilante called the
Reaper who was around in the years
before Bruce Wayne's parents were killed
and even cowboy antihero Jonah Hex who
was hanging around there back in the
1800s and also in the future
it's complicated of course it's one
thing if Batman's not the first
superhero to make his home in Gotham
City but if he's not actually the first
Gotham super
to dress up as a bat well that's a
little weird in 1998 an unexpected tale
in the pages of chase a short-lived but
underrated comic series revealed that
Cameron chases distrust of masked
Avengers came from the fact that her
father was one the Acrobat who fought
crime in the 70s alongside an obscure
and hilariously named team called the
Justice experience unsurprisingly the
story doesn't end well but once you know
he was out there it's hard not to think
that Bruce Wayne was biting his style
the corpse that wouldn't die the
electrocutioner wasn't the only one to
score a technical kill on Batman in the
brave in the bolt number 115 however the
culprit was even less impressive
a booby-trapped rain spout rigged up by
a couple of completely average criminals
the shock did him in but thanks to
Batman's iron Constitution keeping his
heart beating he's only mostly dead
fortunately the atom gets the bright
idea to solve the Batman's final case by
shrinking down and hopping around on his
brain in hopes that this will stimulate
his crime-fighting instincts and allow
him to mindlessly do things like punch
out crooks and rescue a kidnapped girl
and it actually works it turns out that
having a little tiny man hop on your
brain is enough stimulus to basically
jumpstart everything and get you back in
good working order it might not be that
great for the legend of the Batman to
have him die at random by jumping at the
wrong window but that's balanced out by
the fact that death itself cannot stop
him from getting up off a slab in the
morgue and busting criminals jaws all
over Gotham City
[Music]